[Music]  something really weird I think going on  ever since Mexico oh come on  serious I'm seeing things true all right  there dear I know it sounds insane okay  let's play a little game of truth or  dare okay  were there any hookups on Ash I dare you  to tell us on set we all behaved yeah  absolutely did you I think so  truth or dare dare I dare you to show us  secret talent a secret talent I know we  get I can't eat sir week two I can Gleek  yeah my dad might so proud my mom is  probably horrified I dare you guys to  show us the last vote I believe it was a  selfie in my purple dress I was playing  with Sophia's dog  his name is Jack just like my dog Jack I  want to what actor did you like working  with this I'm like if you don't say me  no but also your girlfriend's in the  movie choice in weed but yeah I don't  know everyone brought their underpants  you just say me and I'll say you was  really great working with Tyler  [Music]